أه هذه مقاطع الفيديو الجديدة ، وأنت تعلم
أننا نعرض بعضًا من
أجزاء منها ، لكن من الواضح أنه
مزعج للغاية لما
تراه أنت تعرف أن هذه الاعتداءات على ضباط الشرطة
تزعج هارون بشكل لا يصدق
واليوم أصدرت وزارة العدل
هذه لم يسبق لها مثيل من قبل  تمت مشاهدة
المقاطع وهي في الغالب تأتي من لقطات كاميرا الجسد
ولقطات المراقبة
وتظهر بوضوح مثيري الشغب وهم يضايقون
ويهاجمون الشرطة في السادس من يناير
الآن ، ما يجعل هذه اللقطات
غير عادية هو أنها مأخوذة
من وجهة نظر الشرطة حيث
تم
تجاوزهم وهي مجرد  أحدث تقرير تقشعر له الأبدان بإطار
عن كيف اقتحم الحشد المؤيد لترامب
المباني الفيدرالية
بينما حاولت الشرطة حماية نفسها
والشرطة التي تعتدي على العاصمة هي إحدى التهم التي وجهتها
وزارة العدل
ضد
العشرات من المدعى عليهم في أعمال الشغب من بين
ما يقرب من 500
مجرم اتحادي.  حالات الآن على الرغم من أن مقاطع الفيديو هذه
تم نشرها فقط بعد أكثر من
اثني عشر تقريرًا إخباريًا
قاتلوا بقيادة سي إن إن لجعلهم
يرون هذه المقاطع التي تم استخدامها في
قضايا قضائية ضد المتهمين المتهمين
في الهجوم ،
لكن لم يتم الإعلان عنها حتى
تناضل المنافذ الإخبارية من أجل أن يتمكن الجمهور
من رؤيتها
الآن هذه المقاطع الجديدة التي تم إصدارها  اليوم ، تم استخدامهم على
وجه التحديد
في القضية ضد
جرادي أوينز ، وهو الآن متهم
بمهاجمة الضباط
بلوح التزلج بعد
أن جاء هو وعائلته
إلى العاصمة لدعم جهود الرئيس السابق
لإلغاء انتخابات 2020 ،
والآن أصبح أحد هذه المقاطع في الواقع هو
50 دقيقة وهناك يمكنك أن
ترى في الواقع
أوينز متدرجة تحمل لوح التزلج الخاص به وهي
تتعامل
مع ضباط الشرطة ، وقد تم الآن
اتهام أوينز بارتكاب ست جرائم بما في ذلك
الاعتداء على الضباط بسلاح خطير
يعيق المرور عبر مبنى الكابيتول وأعمال
عنف أخرى
على الأرض حتى يتم دفعه بأنه غير مذنب